as you may know if you've been paying
attention to the news
for the last few days votes are still
being counted in the 2020 presidential
election and joe biden's lead over
donald trump has now actually surpassed
5 million votes and this is i think a
really good time to add some context to
these numbers because
depending on what historical context you
prefer to add
the sort of takeaways from joe biden's
current popular vote win would would be
pretty dramatically different so
with joe biden at close to 77 million
votes
and donald trump at close to 72 million
votes the exact lead for joe biden
as of moments ago was about 5.07 million
votes in other words 5 million plus 70
000 votes and when you look back at the
history of presidential elections this
is not
even close to the largest winning margin
if you're looking at some of the
historical landslides for example
if you look at richard nixon's historic
17 million
vote margin in 1972 if you look at
ronald reagan's in 84 by 16 million
votes
um lbj and fdr won by
15 and 11 million votes respectively
even barack obama
won by more than 9 million votes in 2008
but needless to say this is a healthy
margin for joe biden
and all of the huge wins that i
mentioned just now
came with far larger electoral victories
as well
and that's something not to be ignored
now a really interesting fact is that
among the largest popular vote losses
among candidates who won in other words
popular vote
lost won the presidency electorally
donald trump's popular vote loss in 2016
which was as you remember
by about three million votes to hillary
clinton
is the largest popular vote loss
in history for a candidate who won the
electoral college
and it's followed by george w bush
losing the popular vote by about half a
million
in the year 2000 to al gore and still
winning electorally as you remember
florida
the decider in that particular election
for me
the most interesting perspective on the
number so far
is that joe biden has 50.8 percent of
the vote right now
and when you look at challengers which
accounts for the power of incumbency
remember
removing an incumbent president is
really difficult even an unpopular one
2004
and george w bush's reelection is a
strong reminder of that
among presidential challengers to an
incumbent
joe biden's 50.8 percent which may still
go up
is the highest vote share for a
challenger to an incumbent president
dating all the way back to franklin
delano roosevelt in 1932 who got
57 of the vote as the challenger in 32
and in fact
it's higher at 50.8 joe biden's share of
the vote
is higher even than ronald reagan's
which was 50.7
in 1980 so needless to say
it's a very healthy win popular vote
and yet it came down to a combined
razor thin margin of you know we're
waiting on the georgia results but as of
right now
we're talking about 70 000 votes in
nevada and pennsylvania or you could put
it a different way and say joe biden won
thanks to
60 000 votes in pennsylvania and arizona
depending on what you consider
the winning states for joe biden so what
can we
say more generally we can say that
donald trump's two elections taken
together are remarkable
trump lost the popular vote twice
is one of only 10 incumbents to lose
re-election
and one of only three presidents to be
impeached and if you sort of make a venn
diagram of this
which people have done and have shared
on social media if you take
this together donald trump is the only
president
to lose the popular vote twice be
removed after one term
and be impeached so that's quite a
resume
for him now is there a bigger story than
just
trivia there is but it really depends on
your perspective so on the one hand
how did joe biden manage to almost
lose the electoral college in the middle
of the worst president in the modern
era's
globally embarrassing handling of a
hundred year pandemic
joe biden almost didn't win that's not
good
on the other hand even with republican
voter suppression
republican voter purges trump's election
disinformation
attempted sabotage of the postal service
even with all of that
joe biden still won by more than 5
million votes
and may end up with the exact number of
electoral votes 306 as donald trump had
in 2016
depending on what ultimately happens in
georgia my view is both of these things
are true
we we have to be who what what
right-wing
um pseudo-intellectual said
um reality the world is messy or
something like that
we can hold both ideas at the same time
we have to take the wins where we got
them which is that joe biden won period
and we have to now improve going forward
we have to pour everything we have into
the two senate runoff
races in georgia which we will be
talking about quite a bit tomorrow
and realize that it was close when it
came down to not the 5 million votes
but the under 100 000 votes that the
winning states ended up depending on
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plugin
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman